people of the internet retro records or
here welcome back to harry potter and
the chamber of secrets we
are trying to find neville's toad you
guys
i'm looking for a toad a boy named
neville's lost one indeed he has lost
trevor
but you know what on our way to finding
trevor here's just a random little chest
no incendio no nothing just sitting over
here in a corner
blending in very nicely with the terrain
let's see what we've got here in this
wizard card
wow 1014-1097
fulbert the fearful famous for being so
cowardly he
never ventured out of his house died
when a defensive charm backfired
and the roof fell in yikes
that that almost sounds like a tales of
beetle the bard story right there does
it not
i mean i love those stories in beetle
the bard by the way
i thought they were really fascinating
i haven't read it in a while though
obviously everybody remembers a tale of
the three brothers but i remember there
were some others that
really resonated with me as well or i
don't know if resonates the right word
but
but they uh they were impactful
and well done oh i just heard i just
heard the toad dude
did we find him first first
spot no but but i definitely hear him
so just gotta look around in a couple
more of these rooms here
trevor where are you buddy
if any of you out there know by the way
i i i need your guys help
for the die hard harry potter fans i
need your help down in the comments
so here's trevor we found him what would
be the point you guys think
of having a toad as your pet
like cat obviously i mean cats are
cool i can understand wanting to take
your cat with you to hogwarts
an owl amazing very practical use you
know what
great time to refill on the wickenwell
potion which we used
in last time i was about to say last
week's episode but i don't always
publish these
one week after another but in the last
episode we had to use that wicked mill
potion when we fell
in the incendio challenge chamber uh you
know what while we're here though i
might as well
double check and make sure that there's
no no uh
chests that require incendia or anything
but yeah i never
understood the toad the owl of very
practical
amazing use right can i use incendio on
these guys
that wants me to use defendo i'm just
trying to look around though like
without having to go
i don't really see anything in here that
would be
worthwhile and so we found trevor we
need to go back
to the to the little bulletin board
and then we'll get a wizard card for
that and then we need to be on the
lookout for
any chest with uh incendio pretty sure
already looked over here but oh we can
see in that way though
yeah so there's there is nothing that i
need to do in there
so i think we are completely done with
the greenhouses
all right back inside the castle we are
i'm pretty sure all i need to do
uh is i'm just gonna head back up to
gryffindor tower
and go to the bulletin board
but first you guys i had to make a
couple of stops
along the way in some classrooms and
would you look what i found right here
would you look what i found i knew there
were a couple of these
lurking about that we had seen
throughout our adventure and we said hey
we gotta make sure we come back and so
i just was checking a few of the rooms
and found this one here
all right norvell twunk and yet
another late 1800s you guys
later 1888 to 1957 is when he lived
died saving a non-magical child
from a runaway manticore posthumously
awarded the
order of merlin first class oh well
that's a cool story i mean i hate the
hate that he died but a brave
valiant gentleman right there saving a
muggle basically
all right and we are halfway on our way
to another uh health upgrade which is
always good
all right so let's uh continue on back
up to gryffindor tower now
all right guys would you look at this on
my way back up to gryffindor tower and
we stumbled on another chest this one
requiring defindo to open
that we had missed so there we go yet
another wizard card to add to our list
here let's see what we got
montague nightly montahue nightly
1506-1588 wizard chess
champion dude look at him man
look at him he is not look like
somebody who would be very fun at
parties let's just say that
that guy looked serious
completely serious which is fine you
know which is fine
but i guess that's why he's a champion
wizard chess champion
that's a that's a very serious endeavor
no i don't want to go that way i just
don't want to do it man
i just don't want to do it oh no
oh no take that okay anything else i
need to do in here
oh goodness oh i tried to get away
no i can't believe this man
come on blast him no harry lock on the
lock on does not work very well in this
game at all i was so far away from that
guy are you kidding me
are you kidding me he like blasted me
through the wall oh he's gonna do it
again
yep you know what here i'm blasting them
i'm blasting them
i want my birdie bot beans back
are you serious dude are you serious
right now
get that bean and
there's nothing even up here it was a
waste of time
just get out of here harry just get out
of here
oh my goodness you guys that that was
rough man
i'm kind of ashamed of that one let's
see that's just not good
man that's just i am blasting this guy
how many times do i have to hit him
sheesh now we got to replenish some
not only our birdie bought beans but a
little bit of health as well
how about right here you got anything
for us nice okay
[Music]
all right that helps a little bit half
health and 37 beans
you know not terrible okay wait a second
what was in here that's
locked that's open
that's locked
incendio chest anywhere anywhere oh no
incentive chess but would you look what
we oh
wow have i just completely ignored this
room you guys
have we completely forgotten this room
here's one with uh
no special lock on it at all number 88
celestina warback oh i remember her name
i remember reading about
celestina warback i feel like that name
appears
in the series at some point i could be
wrong though
i could just be remembering it from the
game 1917 to present popular singing
sorceress celestina warbick
all right and then we got another one up
here that's going to require aloha mora
so there's alamora
all right and yet dude we are racking up
the wizard cards right now
number 79 oswald beamish
all right oswald beamish 1850
to 1932 pioneer of goblin
rights okay this one right here guys for
my hogwarts legacy fans out there
i have a whole video up about a big
theory that i have
on how important magical creatures are
going to be
uh for for that game and i think it
makes perfect sense and especially when
you read something like that
like the whole goblin writes
that could be a big thing too um where
they are magical creatures yet they are
very close
to humans if not you know some may even
say smarter than humans in terms of
intelligence i don't i can't remember
the exact lore on that but
um you know wait is that something
what am i hearing
i thought it was like some pixies above
my head or something dude there it is
again
see the shadow over here and then it
disappears
i am so confused man
i think it's actually the fire crabs
but like a floor above or a floor below
i don't know if it's some kind of weird
glitch or if it's like hinting at me
that there's a way for me to get up
there
i have no idea but anyway yeah like
like the whole idea of goblin rebellions
and goblin rights
i think that's gonna be a huge huge part
of the game i really do
okay here we are we finally made our way
back to gryffindor tower
to do what we had originally planned on
doing is going over to the bulletin
board and turning in
trevor neville's toad so we'll get a
wizard card for this
but we also need to check out the next
item here is the
measuring scales last seen near hagrid's
hut if found
please return to the notice board okay
near hagrid's hut
let's see what wizard card we get right
here
and we only need one more number 49
aladora kettleridge
elodora ketteridge 1656 to 1729
which who discovered the use of ghillie
weed when she nearly suffocated after
eating it and recovered only when she
stuck her head into a bucket of water
that that's amazing dude i love that one
i love that one a lot
[Music]
you know what why wait let's go ahead
and head down to hagrid's hut
right now and see i guess it's going to
be in this direction to the forbidden
forest
and see if we can't find those scales
now is it going to be outside his house
or are we going to have to go inside
first let's just kind of look around out
here in this area
oh i promise i promise i did not look
beforehand
i did not look beforehand there we go
the measuring scales
uh i don't even know can you go in
hagrid's house oh that's kind of sad i
wish you could go in and visit with him
i wish you could go in and visit with
with hagrid
oh wait maybe you can maybe you can if
we go here in this door nope
wait why does hagrid have like three
doors by the way
he's got a door there and this i guess
this is just like some little storage
area
and these okay so i got like front and
back door okay
i got it i got it i got it that makes
sense
okay here we are back yet again at the
bulletin board let's go ahead and turn
this one in
we've got another item wizard's hat
dropped while taking a shortcut in the
grand staircase
if found please return to this notice
board okay we're not gonna go and find
that one right now we'll just
you know wait wait till the next day at
least because uh
i'm gonna go ahead and that will upgrade
our health musa
1520-1666 composer
of the unfinished wizarding suite which
features an
exploding tuba its performance has been
banned since its last performance
in 1902 when it blew the roof out of
ackerly town hall wow
wow some interesting wizards and witches
man i tell ya
all right so we are ready to end the day
and see what the knight has in store hey
harry
what do you think of this i was on my
way back oh this is different
when i heard moaning bathroom apparently
someone had tried to flush it down her
toilet
she was in a right state
that told me some books can be very
dangerous here we go dude well we won't
find out unless we look at it
it looks like an old diary belong to tm
riddle hang on i know that name
tm riddle got an award for special
services for the school
50 years ago like how would ron not know
punish his shield about 50 times in
detention
well whoever he was he didn't write in
it it's completely blank
i wonder why someone wanted to try and
get rid of it then weird
like with bronze you said before anyone
else dormitory that night
mainly because he wanted to examine
riddles diary
he sat on his four poster and flicked
through the blank pages
until hello harry potter
my name is tom riddle here we go the
hogwarts and horrible stuff's been
happening
do you know about the chamber of secrets
of course i know about the chamber of
secrets in my fifth year the chamber was
opened and the monster killed a girl
i caught openly i don't think this music
is supposed to be playing right now
it doesn't fit and take you inside my
memory it does not
fit okay harry sat
entranced by the memory tom riddle
showed him
evening hagrid what are you doing down
here tom
it's all over i don't think you meant to
kill anyone
but monsters don't make good pets now do
they it never killed no one
come on the least hogwarts can do is
make sure the thing that killed that
girl is slaughtered it wasn't him
he wouldn't he never no
it was hagrid wrong hagrid opened the
chamber of secrets 50 years ago
go tell hermione did you ever buy that
did you ever buy hagrid opening the
chamber of secrets
not me dude not me
it was hagrid ron hagrid opened the
chamber of secrets 50 years ago
nah dude nah
okay we gotta get outside
dude of course we were just down here
too
like just down here
[Music]
i don't know if you could have gotten
the scales on this mission anyway though
okay now we can go in and visit with
aggregate
a very bad business indeed
things have gone far enough as chairman
of the school
gathers i've simply got to act and send
you
away away away to where
no not the wizard prison not
azkaban i'm afraid so a dreadful thing
dumbledore
as of this moment you are suspended as
headmaster
of hogwarts if the governors want
my removal lucius i shall of course
step aside no
you will also find that help will always
be given at hogwarts to those who ask
for it
of course if anyone wanted to find out
some stuff
all they'd have to do would be to follow
the spiders
that'd lead them right that's dumbledore
should have stepped in and be like
no
looks like he left me a key
it's a shame they didn't have the
invisibility cloak
for this game
oh my goodness you guys is he gonna go
in by himself do we not even have ron
wait and hermione hasn't been petrified
i wonder if she gets petrified in the
game
oh man oh man please tell me i get to
play this
don't take away control oh oh my gosh
dude
okay it's one of me using symbiote on
these guys
oh look at them look at them frantically
run
oh wait why did it why did it take that
one out but
oh no
we gotta hit him again okay gotta hit
them twice with it
yeah it's like at the beginning of the
game when you had to uh
fight the whomping willow
all right let's check out what's oh
goodness
dude incendio takes a little bit longer
to cast
what the heck
dude look at him just standing there
wait what oh
i don't know why it didn't hit hit him
the first time that was weird
oh he's still there how did i not hit
him
all right
no okay the good news is we do have
wigan weld if this gets
too crazy we do have the wig and well
potion
and you can actually cast the pin on
them i would prefer fopindo to be honest
oh wait is lupindo an instant
[Music]
i don't know if it actually takes them
out or if it just like
it definitely makes them go away though
the lock-on was so bad in this game i
don't remember like when i played it as
a kid
i did not remember it being this bad
because i think as a kid you just
assume well that's how that's not
supposed to be but
my goodness this lockdown is rough
it just doesn't work half the time all
right should i go in here first oh yes
we should
because there's another wizard card
who we got here take a break from the uh
number six spider-infested forest
to learn about flavius belby 1715 sorry
to 1791
only wizard ever to survive a lethal
fold attack
oh man the leather folds were
not to be messed with
in fact if you guys remember the leather
fold
go ahead and uh let let everyone know
down in the comments
let everyone know about the leatherfold
oh yeah dude flopindo is way better on
those guys
it's just faster it fires so much faster
what i don't understand
oh that guy kind of appeared out of
nowhere did you see that
we're losing so many beans man we're
losing so many beans
oh no oh no there's a lot in here
[Music]
come on harry blast him there we go
hey incendio this
big time incendio right there anything
over there that we need to do see this
is where like being a completionist get
bites me you know literally right now
literally
the spiders are literally like
spitting i don't know venom or something
at me
and there's absolutely nothing over here
except
this right here i'm just gonna hope
there's none left
okay good all right now let's drop down
oh there he is not exactly but i'm a
friend of hagrid
that's right hagrid has never sent men
into a horror
before hagrid's in trouble that's why
i've come
in
but that was years ago
everyone thought that i was the monster
that dwells in the chamber
of secrets they thought hagrid had
opened the chamber
and set me free which was why
he was expelled man that's
like how could dumble or not come from
the chamber of secrets
no i come from a distant land and
hagrid cared for me i forget how he
couldn't have gotten hagrid
after it was proven that was discovered
in a bathroom
i guess because he wasn't allowed to
have a spider either
apart from the cupboard i grew up in
if it wasn't i know a little bit about
growing up in cupboards
don't you harry i'll just go
then go i think
not but i cannot deny my
children fresh meat
dude yikes
all right come on get him harry
and while we're at it let's just grab a
few birdy bop beans
okay i think we need to go this way
we're gonna have to attack
the big boy up there
but how do we get over there all right i
guess we run back down this way first
oh wait did we go down here
what is the point of this
got a feeling we might be falling in
right there and that's like how you get
back
up or something wait there's more beans
now okay
[Music]
all right try to get them from afar yeah
see like sometimes flipindo just
takes him out really quick
oh here we go right here
nope i knew it
just like rapid fire just rapid fire for
pindo
the do-it-all spell
that's a big incendiary right there and
for some reason the lock-on broke
i'm telling you man the lock-on is like
trash
like see he just got back up from that
incendio
what my goodness
losing birdie bot beans left and right
i'm not even worried about it dude
okay wait can i blast him now
oh there we go oh
geez little ones
is i supposed to blast and cindy over
there what the heck
this little one just appeared out of
nowhere
yeah if they have a lock on system in
hogwarts legacy
oh man they gotta make sure it works
they gotta make sure it works
i don't know nowadays i think games have
pretty much figured out
that third-person camera on and using uh
aim mechanics
oh see the lock on again because i was
locked on to the spider behind it
incendio just like it just doesn't work
you know
oh no here come the little ones yeah i
might as well just go ahead and accept
the fact that
i'm gonna be completely out of berdy
about beans by the time we get done in
here
all right i think we just keep making
our way up
wait do i need to cast incendio on that
though
no nothing happened there
it's how these old school games work man
like are you serious
like things that should totally work
don't unless you're doing
exactly what they want you to do that's
one thing that breath of the wild did so
well
it's giving you that freedom to like
think up ways on your own
to take out certain challenges and meet
certain bosses
[Music]
like there's no way that shouldn't have
hit okay but
kind of afraid to just jump down there
oh no he's right in front of me that is
garbage i'm trying to blast him
this has got to be the way to go though
because it's like so kind of off the
beaten path here
hidden
i just hit this guy twice didn't i
[Music]
this is not really a fun boss fight
either you know
it's kind of boring honestly
like where am i even supposed to go like
what is this dude
did i go the wrong way i probably went
the wrong way
i bet you weren't even supposed to do
that
i bet you weren't even supposed to do
like
go in this little area right here
i bet we were supposed to keep working
our way up oh wait
oh wait yeah keep working our way
up so we can blast more of the web down
yeah it's going to be easy i knew it was
going to hit me
there's a chest right here though okay
fine it was worth it
as long as it's a wizard card yeah there
we go
more wizard cards you'd love to see it
all right take a break from fighting the
spider to read about
another weird sisters group member plays
loot with the popular wizarding band the
weird sisters
all right very cool very cool
and i'm gonna take a hit oh i thought i
was totally gonna take a hit for that
okay so i guess this is the only way to
go then
is to go down this way all right so we
were in fact going the right way
however by turning back it did help us
to find that wizard card
all right so i feel like we're supposed
to go across
like lock on him again
oh my goodness dude
like half the time it's better just to
run him and fire
instead of trying to lock on grab these
beans
i really should use the dodge mechanic a
little more
[Music]
like that right there
probably what it's meant for
oh my goodness dude i'm all the way back
down to the bottom again
am i not back at the bottom
and these guys just keep repeatedly
emerging from
everywhere
all right well this thing still has very
about beans so that's a good sign that i
haven't been this way yet
and a pumpkin pasty
more spiders to destroy oh
i see like right there would have been a
perfect time for the dodge
oh right there it was a good dodge
yeah i see like if you're gonna lock on
then you gotta use that dodge to your
advantage
all right surely we are getting close
oh you like that the fire and the dodge
okay right here nope oh i pushed the
wrong button i was trying to dodge
would have worked anyway because i'd let
go of my lock on
are you serious right before i cast
incendio
he's in a tough spot too
can i just like blast them right now
please
let's just let's just end this aragog
let's go dude you already see where this
is going
we know where this is going aragog come
on man
like lock on lock on lock on
oh no not this wall sneak garbage
now is not the time that i want to be
wall sneaking i just want to go fight
aragog
get this over with and be done
like any boss fight that intentionally
makes you
slow down multiple times oh okay that's
kind of cool though
that's that's that's kind of cool though
perfect spot to use that
another pumpkin pasty that's big time
like shoot the guy in front of me there
it is again man there it is again this
stupid lock on like
it's firing at the guy three feet behind
him
another pumpkin and we are almost back
to max health which is really nice
i think i actually don't remember what
happens once we get
because obviously we're going around
right now we're gonna have to knock out
all the webs
and then aragog's probably gonna fall
but then is that it or is there
something else that we have to do do we
like drop down and do battle with him
oh my goodness uh
uh it's the little things man it's the
little things they add up
oh no no back away
okay
[Music]
this is the last one
no are you kidding me right now
all right well that was nice
and another wizard card that's nice as
well we'll take it
number 64 jacinda sykes josunda
sykes 1915 to present famous for flying
across the atlantic on a broomstick
the first person to do so
that's pretty cool i like that all right
let's blast
this with its india oh this
there we go
oh no harry don't fall
are you kidding me
okay that's legit terrifying
that's legit terrifying
oh my goodness man
oh okay this answers our question
we do actually have to do battle with
him
oh and that was a direct hit oh no
harry run okay i don't think i can worry
about the beans in here man
okay what do i do here what do i do here
we can't jump
that's just not even fair man
like you don't even have enough time to
dodge that
okay there we go blasting
yeah i think you just gotta you gotta be
out of the lock on
to be able to run more kind of freely
like this yeah then you can get around
them
dude it feels so weird like not having a
sprint button
not having a roll
lock on to him
oh wow yeah i really want that bean
i guess that's what we're worried about
right now
oh my gosh okay blasting
all right what maybe two more hits you
think
get away from that harry get away from
that
oh he's up again no
no no no no no no we missed our chance
there we go hey hey i'll take it
i will take it is that another vial
let's go
another wicked will potion vial
so now we get two oh now the car shows
up
now the car he's here oh and ron's in
there too let's go
get out of there get out of there ron
follow the spiders
you're lucky to be alive we now know
that hagrid never opened the chamber of
secrets
indeed wait a minute something aragog
said
ron that girl who died aragog said she
was found in a bathroom
what if she never left the bathroom what
if she's still there
what if she is what if she
is if it was oh in all the excitement i
forgot
someone's been up to the dormitory and
taken the diary
what i went to look for hermione but i
could find him
oh no what
afraid so but only a gryffindor could
have stolen it
nobody else knows our password exactly
anyway yep i'm off to bed see you harry
see you ron and thanks for rescuing me
you're my best friend
run dude it's just like all this stuff
going on
anyway i'm off to bed
i'm off to bed harry oh my goodness ron
that's yeah i'm just i'm off to bed
not you know hermione i can't find her
but i'm going to bed
guys i think i'm going to go to bed as
well i think this is a good spot to stop
as any uh you can definitely tell we are
getting close to the end if you all
enjoy this video make sure to give it a
thumbs up before you go that's gonna
help more people find this video
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon